rhettandlink good mythical morning to
you guys it's Breton links buddy system
we're on the set it is we are on one of
the sets where is this place this is the
creepy warehouse where we're having a
prom reenactment tell me about this show
what can we expect from it how did this
idea come about so it's the story of
Linc losing his phone and the existence
of our daily show good mythical morning
being brought into danger by a co
ex-girlfriend who is now an infomercial
queen and we have to go on some crazy
adventures to get it back you know as a
matter of fact I currently in real life
do not know where my phone is
now leslie bibb is the co ex-girlfriend
that's gonna bring you down how did she
get involved in this our co
ex-girlfriend in real life from middle
school
her name was Leslie yes we dated her at
different times though so we were
looking for Leslie and she's super super
hilarious it's also you know I wanna be
there this Leslie has an e on the end of
Leslie R Leslie just had her I just
ended in a tie I mean she's not our
Leslie she's married well she wasn't we
thought about making the spelling of
Leslie a requirement but you don't meet
a lot of Leslie's without the e so we
were like Leslie Bibb she's great she's
a Leslie all right now in your a big
announcement video that went up recently
you teased a lot about this show I need
one nugget you haven't given away yet
what can you tell ET about the show
there's a shipwreck there's not a
shipwreck
there's a flying exercise bike so you
say there's not one of tho no there
there is a flying exercise bike okay
there we go
I'll take that nugget I'll take it all
right what are you gonna dip that nugget
in no ranch dressing
I like Polynesian Rhett I'm not a Dipper
I do dry nuggets dry nuggets
all right page Breton links buddy system
we're here on the set is a creepy
warehouse and it's pretty scary and I'm
glad it's daytime tell us about your
character how are you involved in this
wacky misadventure of the boys I play
Maxwell and Maxwell is an old high
school friend of Retton links and you
know they gone their separate ways and
they meet up again in the interesting
situation and way and then they
just rekindle their friendship and it's
just like the same old thing that they
used to do back in high school so it's
great you know infomercials are a part
of this I want you to give me your best
sale of this show as if it were an
infomercial coming later this year
that's actually a blockbuster movie
introduction so I don't know that was
good for infomercial but listen rhett
and Link buddy system is a fun and wacky
comedy that you're going to enjoy that
everyone can enjoy it comes out later
this year it has Paige Kennedy in it hi
what can go wrong with that you just got
a tune in a lot of lera t would ensue
hey guys if you liked what you saw make
sure to subscribe
you